imagine having a superpower to predict
the future using data
predicting the future with data is more
of a reality than make-believe in
today's competitive business world
Business Leaders are constantly seeking
a competitive advantage in hiring High
performing individuals with strong
business analytical expertise who can
connect the dots from data analysis to
profitable business outcomes
take your data skill set to the next
level with udacity's business
intelligence analytics nanodegree
program in this program Learners will
Deep dive into business intelligence
analytics and understand how it is
leveraged across Industries
Learners will identify the type of data
analytics strategy used in a given
situation and where they stand in the
data analytics lifecycle they will learn
how to load clean and organize different
types of data with power query and
discover the full capabilities of power
bi
this program also covers Concepts such
as classification regression and
forecasting as well as other various
techniques allowing Learners to practice
predictive data analysis with a Hands-On
approach
this Hands-On learning will give
Learners the confidence to develop
data-driven predictions identify future
risks and examine potential growth
opportunities if you are ready to
forecast a better future using data then
enroll in udacity's business
intelligence analytics nanodegree
program today